there's new information first reported
by CNN but confirmed Now by CBS news
that could mean more legal trouble for
former president Donald Trump the former
president was recorded talking about a
classified document that he kept after
leaving the White House dozens of papers
marked classified you'll recall were
seized from his Florida home last year
and our senior investigative
correspondent Catherine Herridge is
following all these developments at the
justice department for us Catherine good
morning
Good morning Tony the audio tape is now
part of the special counsel criminal
investigation and sources tell CBS News
it was the focus of recent grand jury
testimony here in Washington
two sources familiar with the matter
tell CBS News the audio tape is from a
meeting two years ago at former
president Trump's New Jersey Golf Club
more than a year before Federal
investigators searched his Mar-A-Lago
estate in Florida and seized records
marked classified the existence of the
tape was first reported by CNN two
sources say the recording captures Trump
acknowledging there are National
Security restrictions on the Pentagon
memo the detailed potential plans to
attack Iran One Source said that Trump
stated he should have Declassified the
record before leaving the White House
apparently contradicting recent claims
at a CNN Town Hall I have no classified
documents and by the way they become
automatically Declassified when I took
them in his autobiography Trump's former
Chief of Staff Mark Meadows appears to
describe the New Jersey meeting where
Trump recalls a four-page report that
contained a plan to attack Iran
deploying massive numbers of troops he
possessed the classified document and he
the intent to possess that Scott
Fredrickson is a former Federal
prosecutor this is a huge piece of
evidence for the special counsel it'll
be highly influential in the decision of
whether or not
to indict the former president and
certainly if there were to be a trial
this would be Mighty powerful evidence a
tape recording of the president himself
in an interview on CNN Trump attorney
Jim trustee did not dispute the facts of
the reporting but accused the FBI and
Justice Department of elite campaign the
special counsel declined to comment but
there are indications that his
investigation into Trump's handling of
classified information may be in its
final stages Nate
Catherine thank you